a sólo 25 kilómetros de kiev bloquear el
avance ruso en el ping era fundamental
para las fuerzas ucranianas pero no
queda mucho de lo que un día fue un
suburbio y lleno de vida sus calles
residenciales y edificios están marcados
por el fuego de artillería y la ciudad
está siniestra mente tranquila desde
principios de marzo no hay agua gas ni
electricidad y la mayoría de los
residentes de irving huyeron esta mujer
es una de las pocas personas que quedan
en su barrio se llama y elena y tiene 65
años
ninguno de mis vecinos se quedó todos
fueron evacuados
después de casi 40 días de guerra rara
vez ha salido de su apartamento
me estaba volviendo loca en mi
apartamento el dios por favor sálvame
sálvame el bombardeo fue aterrador mira
a tu alrededor
de los archivos 70.000 habitantes de la
ciudad quedan unos 3500 gran parte de
ellos son mayores y vulnerables no te
oye cómo voy a salir de mi casa estoy
sola espere a que me ayudarán antes todo
esto era tan bonito eran muy bonitos y
ahora mira todo es una tragedia
el viernes un equipo de trabajadores de
la cruz roja pudo acceder al centro de
la ciudad para proporcionar alimentos y
ayuda esencial en este parque cercano
algunos de los residentes de irving
fueron enterrados aunque las tropas
rusas han sido forzadas a salir de el
fin la ciudad sigue estando al alcance
de la artillería enemiga